what right does someone have to put that
body in physical or even mortal danger
the main way this usually gets skirted
around is that the danger is the result
of pursuing the means to reverse the
swap yes it's physical harm but it's in
the pursuit of a goal that the body's
original owner would want that takes the
curse off it a little bit but we're not
done yet because there's issues of Fraud
and defamation because somebody else
running around in your body can pull all
kinds of activities I'll have my brakes
on your desk by lunch that puts my balls
on your chin by dinner that right there
is schedule for sexual harassment
awesome usually if this comes up it's
played for comedy like most other things
with this Trope and it also tends to
either get resolved or the characters
actually decide that the consequences
are in fact a good thing which a bit
like the endangerment angle takes a as
long as it's all okay in the end we
don't have to question the fact about
whether or not it should have happened
in the first place approach